what up everyone I knew I just thought I
literally didn't wanna thirds we're fine
everything's fine nothing's there it's
good we're here to play Red Dead
Redemption - it's finally out today's a
day and we're very excited
both John Luke and I I believe we both
started it last night we're we're only a
little bit in we're past the prologue
which is when the game really opens up
yeah we were originally thinking about
playing the prologue but playing it it's
it's it's a little restrictive yeah in
terms of gameplay it's very story heavy
very restrictive and I don't think that
makes for a good stream yeah so I
thought we would maybe get to the second
chapter yes well with the game kind of
truly opens up well mess around with all
that the game is actually loading right
now I'd switch over to the screen so you
can see it oh there it is watch pop
right in boom alright so we're in you've
got a gruff Arthur oh yeah man I'm doing
it up I'm also I'm playing a bad guy cuz
apparently no one else in our office did
well then I can I can just shoot
everybody yes so go ahead and this is
it's the Wild West - do what you got to
do but yeah so this is right after that
they learn just we're not right today
yes just say yes yeah you know what that
means it's letting you know that that
that autosave is over writing the last
autosave but uh yeah
so this is right after the intro we're
not gonna spoil that we're also we're
gonna play some story stuff but I don't
feel like it's gonna be very like
spoiler spoiler II but mostly is just
kind of like a hey wait some dominoes
for good yeah there you go let's just do
an hour 40 minutes yesterday playing
poker and then I was like oh I should
probably uh do something else so crime
says I haven't even touched any missions
after the prologue and I've played for
five hours that's kind of how it goes
dude for sure so yeah you kind of get
this opening area here we got
Valentine's a very cool town have you
done the bounties yet I started them so
I talked to the the stranger and started
it off I haven't tracked any of them
down yet though
okay well won't we do some of those
those are fun
can you rob banks without doing main
missions i I assume you can rob
like stories and stuff yeah I don't
think I've come across to mr. Naugle run
if you didn't in settings and is that a
thing like like an actual toggle toggle
run ability so we're learning this stuff
along with you guys because like I said
Jonah can I both started playing
yesterday we have run mode toggle toggle
can run what's that do it means I think
when you tap where you hit exit it'll
he'll already be running and you won't
have to actually hold it down so you
can't running camp so it's not a good
show of it but yeah I don't have to hold
it down oh my god whoever put that
that's crime crime shut us to crime
after crime it's a good call
I really hope it comes to PC i me too
but I've only played a little bit but I
am very certain that I will double dip
if it comes out on PC because oh yes
beautiful right now
imagine it running on a computer
definitely so I let's see here so you
think we're going off the Valentine here
to see what's up yeah well well you're
saying the UH there's those bounties we
have so I could oh yeah you can check
those out Dom photographs here we go so
we got these photograph look at these
photographs these are like these
gunslingers that we need to go find and
ask for like a book this quest is very
Rockstar by the way yeah like once you
get into this game I was like oh right
this is like a rockstar game feels very
like GTA ish in that like there's this
guy who's writing a book for this like
drunken yeah gotten slinger and he's
just like I'm tired of dealing with this
look man like I honestly like [ __ ]
kill me kill me or kill him someone
needs to die themselves we got to go
find her
let's see last reported in blue water
Marsh so cool then we can go to the next
one I do like how you can kind of see
the actual influence from all the other
rockstar games in here like this is very
silly are being able to turn and flip
over things in the yeah it's pretty cool
this guy
look over here that kind of deal but
yeah and we got this guy as well all
right no problem though now they've all
popped up on the map
oh it actually marks them it marks them
all on the map oh that's wonderful
so we got this guy right over here we
can go do it if we want so there's
there's this uh apparently if you turn
off the the mini-map or whatever it
changes the dialogue does so or like
people giving you questions from another
I really like is if you hold down the
button it just lets you do it oh you
just do it that way so you don't have to
go into the menu and so you can change
it on the fly and the nice thing is when
you have it turned off if you just tap
the button it brings everything again
holy cow everything's there so if you
are like I want to play it without it
but just oh I just need to occasionally
check it yeah yeah it's useful because
there are times where for example I had
it turned off and it was it was cool the
guy would be like oh uh just just go
follow the river and then two trees down
take a left
followed it and it was pretty cool but
then at one point they were like park by
that bar and I'm like okay so I parked
to the left of the bar and they're like
you're going the wrong way and then I
pulled up the map and was like now I
wanted me to park up the right side of
the barn oh so it's not entirely
specific but it yeah occasionally it
kind of gets in the way it's really cool
because it reminds me of like it's just
really interesting because it's coming
up where everyone's gonna finally be
able to play like the beta version of
the vanilla warcraft remake but in the
original warcraft if people never played
it you would actually have to read quest
text because there was no tracker for
anything and the idea of an open-world
game from someone like Rockstar where
you actually have to like listen to
directions and be done this so this this
guy is just like hey man do you want to
you want to have a friendly competition
is this oh wait let me get my uh let me
get my I got to get a good rifle so this
is just like a shooting competition deal
yeah so that's not my horse but wait
that's a standby horse oh no so I don't
have anything on that horse shoot all
right I'm gonna have to use them over
all right let's do it
have you tried the companion app I
actually downloaded it before this
don't have any had because I have
Android and Android one went up kind of
later
but alright so uh there's gonna be a
little bit tough just use that I I'm
gonna save the die
schemas is perfect I'm I'm having a very
good time with it all right
I'll be a oh look I love how animated he
is when he's upset when he lost better
shot I suppose I need to like reveal my
dead eye here
oh it wasn't it wasn't full up now fully
restores Dead Eye slightly damaged
instead I core though ask her it say my
safe do that thing so now he's like
alright let's raise it he's just really
happy that someone's out here to finally
shoot with him so now it's the birds oh
no your stamina going down from the hot
jacket made it so it it says that it's
good for like regular weather but oh
this pistols too far away for me to
properly I also like how he knows doing
this I had the rifle do hip fired for
that too I should have mentioned that I
don't think that's my horse because I
saw it I did it I actually didn't do it
last time I got more than me so you just
need the revolver it's all about the
revolver and actually unlocked the
sharpshooter challenge for you heck yeah
so he cheats and she yeah they're
they're actually a lot of outfit options
I don't know if it's because I bought
the Ultimate Edition and I got something
in there but so when I lost you actually
have to go up to him and give him the
money
oh so you can say no screw you I'm not
giving you the money and leave and
that's when I would be able to do my bad
guy move and probably just shoot him
anyway yeah so I am I like even the
money and I was like I you win and then
I talk to him on my email is pretty good
shooting like I I'm really appreciating
all these small little details I love
how I said it earlier today and I was
trying to find the word for it while I
was playing last night but I love how
tangible everything feels like
you can you can go inside of a general
store and you can actually walk around
inside of the shop and like you pick up
the items you know yes I want to plug
Simon toss under drain right there you
go yeah just sir is there a trophy for
that this time around this is bird I
just put that bird in my that whole bird
inside your pouch Oh another thing I
keep doing is I keep being like I'm
gonna go down this cliff and then it's
just my [ __ ] horse crumbles real talk
if you guys haven't seen the horse crash
physics Oh
all right we're just going down here and
then yikes
that fell right on the rock and then the
horse takes a good oh no okay it did it
quicker in mind the horse took like 30
seconds to get back up and I felt really
bad that's uh that's a hungarian half a
half-breed man they're very strong jeez
but yes the in the cool thing about it
is like the horse is intelligent it'll
try to steer clear of like trees and
stuff but you can also still trick it
and you can hit things head-on yeah
somebody's saying uh looking fair I play
free but Rome online there is no online
yet so the online isn't here yet is it
next month and a month so it'll be a
beta there'll be a beta and you better
believe we're all gonna Posse up and
hang out and read Redemption to online
cuz this is normally a community day
stream where we play with you guys but
jean-luc I both realized that with Red
Dead Redemption two out who's going to
want to bother with playing anything
other than that so we just kind of were
like let's just have a red dead day
let's hang around and check out what's
going on so this is the guy we're
supposed to talk to you do will hand
guns Kenny yeah got on lock it though
used to be correct first thing I did was
like shave you gave him like a nice cuz
he doesn't need the beard he has a
really nice jawline it gave me the
warning about my beard growing really
far and I just was like cool I'm not
gonna show you also have to like get it
maintained yeah I'm letting it go I'm
just letting it grow as much as gonna
get beard oil make him look real real
ugly yeah
some some bad facial hair you can give
him my talking and shovel somebody crime
says some NPCs can escape hot I put one
of the train tracks and then he got out
and ran away
oh no how do you do it so I I don't know
the exact specifics of it but I know you
can get a second holster somewhere along
the line probably like crafting through
skinning animals or whatever and you can
do wheeled I I know that I saw like a
revolver and a shotgun oh man this is so
yeah I had to get this guy to tell me
the story I have to clean up this manure
for him through a shitty situation and
he's talking about how he's like yeah
I've killed the ton of people scalp him
I've killed so many men music it's
happening this is nice it's very
unpleasant man just this so maybe there
is something I'm missing cuz there are a
lot of people who are calling out that
the jacket that having been wearing but
I think it's a light jacket I think it's
alright while people are claiming that
you are you're wearing an inappropriate
jacket forbid I like the jacket though
it looks cool when I get back to camp
and yeah we can mess around with the
outfit that's fine
what camera options you all find best
I'm trying to find the right settings so
all I did was I'm not sure what the
default was but I tapped the button a
couple of times tonight I'm taking the
middle like one I like I usually like
the one farthest away I usually do too
but I feel like the close ones very very
close first of all too close I'll go
with the middle one as well yeah but
outside of that I haven't messed with
too many of the other camera settings so
I've been keeping it at middle middle
range I don't mess with the first place
premises they're in the same jacket it's
fine so Kranz got our back there you go
it's a cool jacket can you play with
your friends in the campaign I don't
know but if if they continue off of what
the original read that online was there
might be taught machines again which
were kind of fun also very hard they're
just kind of like ah you and three your
friends got a head down to the mines you
get the gun out of the bottom of the
mine how do you feel about the emphasis
on realistic animations that was
Callie's only real like major negative
in her review was that the realistic
animations kind of sometimes get in the
way of like just like playing the game
like kind of like clumsy like falling
around like you're walking and it has
that thing where it's like the animation
has to like finish playing out because
they're trying to make it realistic you
have like momentum when you're in a in a
closed building it feels kind of clumsy
that was an issue people had with which
were three yeah she had to make an
alternate like movement to fix it
alright I'm gonna blow up this guy's
down in my Arab those guys many more
with dynamite I'm curious how you feel
about yeah I'm feeling it a little bit
where I'm like yeah I'm not having too
rough of a time with it the only time
it's it's been a thing for me I think is
when I go to pick up a hat off and round
and I'll try to walk forward a little
bit but I'll walk over it and then I
have to like stop and walk back oh I've
got to mathematically walk to things
forward than one back to be able to pick
it up no that's a real shitty situation
I love him he's great I really like
Arthur
yeah Arthur's great he's um he's a real
sarcastic [ __ ] yeah which is why I
don't feel too bad okay thing a bad guy
see so now
Oh slowly press r2 dude you you you blew
up that guy's like poop collection all
over him and then you killed him
alright and I get take a nice photo
which is you have a special his gun he
does he a special guy unnamed gun
I think messed much with the photo stuff
it's pretty good I haven't gotten to do
too much with it so you can take yeah
first let's grab this gun here so I can
grab his revolver it's not I don't feel
like the bad or the movement's bad but
it is definitely different there's
something there's something there no no
it's not that the movement is bad it's
just that it's um it's very different
and it's an emphasis on realism and I do
think there are moments where that feels
like you're fighting against it when you
don't want it - yeah I want to be really
cool and pick up the hat right away and
then I end up walking back and forth
like so now we got his special revolver
which is pretty good so yeah um
there are definitely quests that you
want to do that that give you special
like guns yeah there that are worth
getting so from what I'm hearing from
everyone else who's been playing much
more than I have make sure you do side
quests like if you see sides stuff pop
up check it out because there's a chance
you could actually miss things
apparently yeah I'm gonna take a take a
selfie here ah perfect see give yourself
a good expression so selfie mode in Red
Dead Redemption - compared to Yakuza how
do you feel which which ones got a bit
old and shoot you can post up yeah it's
like it's like when I shot like a deer
except I killed a man oh man dang it's
pretty dumb scheme looks so good that's
literally the thing that I think about
all the time I can't believe that a game
is out looks this good rang on console
for sure yeah it constantly looks like
just a tech demo oh let me uh there's
this really gross animation
I need my horse Gilgamesh it's a good
name for a horse
I'm coming in clutch
yeah kisses got her selfie system I love
it I was kind of hoping when it said
like portrait mode I was hoping he would
just hold the camera like yes and it's
just him holding it for like two hours
so it develops properly but this chicken
skinning animations real gnarly oh here
we go with his bare hands
wraps it up puts it in his pouch excuse
me hold on I don't I don't not look
yikes how strong do you have to be with
your thumbs alone to just rip open a
chicken right where did your horse go so
you can't maybe it ran away oh not to
run back to camp oh let's get back to
camp let's get your proper horse and
let's change the outfits then something
I haven't messed with a lot but I want
to is hunting because hunting is pretty
involved in it yeah there's a lot to it
there's so much I want to touch there's
so much to do so you so much do you so
much to see so what's wrong with taking
the back street you'll never know if you
don't go nailed it perfect that's my
mandatory one Smash Mouth reference
today thank you for playing hey Bob
Jones how you doing it's a real cowboy
style oh man I used to work at a KFC
before you my Dutch it all makes sense
now you can't work at a KFC unless you
you've mastered the barehanded chicken
all right is that one yours it's it's
still the default one I'm supposed to
have a warhorse but I haven't figure out
how to use it yet that's the that's the
downside of not having your uh it's my
camp
no no yours is that one over over the
lines this one right here yeah let's
change some clothing out oh there you go
yeah let's let's get dressed for the
occasion so like hey you got the full
outfits but then I'll see you get you
can make your own customized oh yeah we
got the gunslinger summer gunslinger
it's the summer gun sling is it suitable
for hot temps we're fine
yeah this we wouldn't wear average temps
a hot hot tents average hot times that
was kind of a nice I like how many
options there are for outfits though
like you can you cannot just wear like
coats and shirts but you've got like
vests and stuff and you can store some
of it on the horse you know if it's like
you're gonna go to the winter you can
like put in the winter outfit on the
horse and then you can like move it
around when you when you switch Bob
Jones says has anyone watched the the
streams notice that there's some
harshness in the Mike's this week maybe
or something got messed up at some point
well uh we'll have to take a look at it
have have our people look into this
apologize it for our people talk to your
people
too too intense right now though I want
to I want to look at the shaving as well
I thought if you didn't pitch the horse
correctly you would run away I think
that might be what happened earlier
probably you're getting rid of my beard
well if I give you like a a blinking I
mean hey you know what if I just give
you like gross that's a heck of a
statement mutton chops are like we can
get the beard and we can keep the baby
I just kind of wanted a show show off a
bit look at these options you
really cool if you could like I don't
know freestyle it you know like yeah oh
I feel like you have pomade to like make
your hair look yeah nice and suave is it
born to be multi-player yes there's a
beta next month which hopefully will be
just as great as reddit online the
original one I'm very excited for it
this has got to be your horse that looks
like the default one yes it is that's it
we got horse collar the Tennessee Walker
worth cargo so the other thing that I
don't diss your horse not have its so
they do but you can't you can't mess
with it until you take it out of camp oh
that's weird
yeah I haven't spent too much time at
the camp I kind of just like went off
and let's go find another one of those
people hey yeah let's go on an adventure
let's go on an adventure I like you do
some hunting odd thing if you shave in
town you do have more options I didn't
know that because I stumbled into it
inside the saloon and the guy was like
why don't you sit down and see what did
he do the bounty uh yes that was pretty
good did you um so one thing I like is
that the game has like different ways
that can play out did you uh did you
save him when he fell off the cliff yeah
I didn't and he fell into the river and
then I had to do this whole extended
sequence where had to chase him down the
river and like yell ahem I'll be like
mr. hit the get to the could get to his
side sorry that ended up happening
anyway oh really
so he ended up still jumping in oh man
that's like that's kind of less cool but
it's in school that you can customize
and tailor it to what happens I thought
maybe like I would have completely avoid
that sequence if I got him that's all
right yeah it's a little less impressive
when I give the game credit for an
output but you had the illusion of it I
had the illusion and then I crushed it
and crush my illusion this game's trash
now can't believe it literally
unplayable standard a pro this is a
press on a pro ya know if you're getting
I mean I think you're getting like I'm
not sure what the resolution and
settings are like so because we're
obviously not playing it in 4k but I
don't know if it's like Dom sampling it
or if it's
so from what I understand the the
PlayStation one runs at it's not 4k Xbox
one does or Xbox one X runs at 4k and
your frame rates like around 30 to 20
pretty much where you are depending
finish killing
I mean yell at him right in the leg
right in the foot hey wombo combo both
of those guys yeah yikes
the guy's got a cool hat though hey
what's up dude I got you it's all good
hey so I've been told
all right say you got you got some free
loot give a repeater uh I should wrap it
off this dude I like have to glue your
guns yeah yes I could actually buy like
gun oil and like maintain your weapons
cheek melon says it's 2160 on the pro
and native 4k on the X there you go
I'm not I've not been disappointed at
all in the way this looks though it
looks amazing
he'd lock breaker dang I don't have a
lot shoot occur just shoot it can you
try Oh horses horses horses is that
horse I don't want to shoot him then
horse get run over there was a man in
of that coach that got run over and both
him and his horse are dead now is that
what happened yeah oh that one's up the
guy who went away
no no Oh shot gun let's grab that heck
yeah
Oh this guy's what the heck's going on
here
what in tarnation oh my god
hey fun fact you could shoot out blocks
there you go just make sure there are no
horses attached to the Carter people
aren't around otherwise you might end up
doing like a double murder holy [ __ ]
that's cool I didn't even think about
that like you could just shoot the lock
off it's C I mean that outlaw mentality
I'm like how do I break into things how
do i seal things
shoot the locks this game has a level of
detail where I feel like I can do
anything to the point where when I can't
do something I'm like oh right I guess I
can't do everything like I saw like an
axe or something I was like I could
probably pick that up yeah no I guess I
can't pick that up but I'm like it feels
like you can anyway so that happened
just gonna ride out of here mosey on out
of here oh this way I feel like I feel
like the amount of horse crashes we've
experienced is a lot of horse murder Oh
No hey there's some some hunting some
hunting some hunting action ok the bow
should be on there yeah right there we
go
grab that bow I do like that you have
like a separate inventory that's just on
your horse and it makes like you have to
really like make sure your horse is
around you because you can't just call
them from anywhere now they have to be
within earshot okay let's see here so
let's focus them tracks you're tracking
us an interesting thing too you got to
be like really patient it demands a lot
can you guys give away a ps4 if I had a
ps4 to give away you know I would okay
I kind of lost track of the tracks here
little subtle there we go
becoming as dishonorable is yeah crime
about that dishonorable life kijima
games have that level of detail
sometimes yes I do I do like that about
Kojima Games
I do like Kojima games a lot I always
appreciate games that are able to put in
extra little touches I think they they
enhance the experience definitely do you
think there will be a patch to fix ps4
pro fork a problem and texture BAM I
haven't seen any texture problems but
personally but I mean I'm sure Rockstar
will will patch it up - yeah if there's
anything wrong with it I'm sure they'll
work on it
okay let's skin this so I'm just gonna
skin it on the Sun site do the skinning
animations are I like how they went from
like not showing it in the first leg way
up and here it is all of it anyway I got
this the skin now and II got some meat
remorse over here I'm taking canoe and
swim to Blackwater yeah a wife to make
space space yeah you're out of space oh
I like to collect a lot of things
well we can if I get the horse over here
just sitting there like come on any time
there he is
they're having a rough time with it that
it's real difficult to get my or grease
these are how you doing welcome to the
stream so what so let's stow that skin
do we want to put the hold Iran as well
maybe cuz we can we connect to the camp
did you fold the skin out as like like a
blanket so like it kind of looks like
yes I did okay I mean do it that's a
good now I couldn't put the that's a
level of animation detail that damn
those are rock star people yeah yeah
alright do you want head back to camp
and yeah give them give him this this
cool cool hunting deer so they were
saying you get like rewards for bringing
like stuff back yeah actually where are
we there's just a lot of like incentive
to to actually contribute to the camp
yes I wish that there was a way that I
can contribute not gain honor for it
though cuz I'm trying to be bad but it's
it's negating out my bad deeds crime
with the hot tips while on the horse
press let's stick to pet it and progress
in the bonding yeah you to pet your
horse all the time you'd spent dogs in
this video game it's real good you can
also call out to the dog and make them
come over to pet it's great you have to
like full stop to do it though I do yeah
there it is give them good pets that's a
good horse
you're a good strong horse will be
available for PC you don't know what's
up but I'd like to I'd like to have it
on PC
get our three swim I think so right I
feel like Arthur should be able to swim
I haven't run into any opportunities to
you think we've long passed
the days of Assassin's Creed 1 well I
mean even in Red Dead 1 John John can't
swim oh really yeah it's hilarious
because if you like because he had that
weird rage engine physics thing going on
so if like dynamite were to blow up next
to you while you're on like the side of
a river your character would like
stumble and then like fall over and to
like 3 feet of water and then then game
over Oh John got too wet so H this horse
up I don't know where to actually put
the I guess give it to the guy got to
give it to the cook get to the butcher
guy yeah yeah also I like how you can
kind of chain animations so when you
were hooking your horse up you could
actually hold down square to go straight
from getting off the horse hooking them
up and then also grabbing it all in one
animation which is nice where is he oh
that soups ready though I think just
drop it in front of him I think so
I brought you this whoa hey what she's
kind of teleported me I dropped the camp
we'll always left in a convenient
location I'll be handed in at the
counter she had to take a sweet
encounter a counter okay so I'm just
kind of drop it anywhere in the camp it
just puts it in like a spot but I have
to go to his counter specifically okay
so she drop it on the top I know to you
here in this game out Oh
also the days in this game are really
long yeah right this has got to be as
counter like or here yeah I think this
is the counter this has to be it yeah
donate I'm donating this take this
entire dear oh hi donate all this stuff
you want yeah go for it
lay it out donate all
[Music]
okay well I guess I didn't donate them
or was it not in the list like the one
of the right oh yeah there we go there
you go the whole thing donated we did it
oh there we go
crime says you can swim but you can't
dive no grades yes so so from here we
can then crack upgrade the camp so is
this where you actually get like the
second holster for a revolver then
because if that's where it happens your
boys about to do a whole bunch of
hunting to make sure you can get that
second the satchel the second holder no
it's just the satchel thing that's good
though I want to upgrade all this stuff
same so looks like there are different
types of satchels like this is for King
more provisions for carry more materials
more provisions means more candy bars
I'm just gonna breaking yeah why can you
upgrade his he wants a boar skin rug and
that's it
chuck wagon put sweet skull on our wagon
hmm more skulls skulls on everything it
doesn't seem like that's where we can
upgrade our okay I like saying hi to
everyone
yeah it's the conversations are very
pleasant I just said tell us your honest
opinion on this game rate for ten points
we don't do that we don't do it all so
if I if I were to I haven't played
enough for this game to be able to do it
yet yeah I've played three hours but
what I can say is I'm enjoying it a lot
I like it quite a bit it's pretty good
having a very good time with this Wild
West boy let's inspect this letter nope
or just get up on there ah yeah I could
do that to you the the uniform way of
inspecting letters just jumping on top
of the box oh wow
I'm glad too they have the option to
read it like this once the second hole
so you have to go hunt there
dude let's go on some bears to find some
bears dang is a pretty pretty game that
first person I keep hitting the this
thinking it's the map same it's really
weird that because it is like a uniform
thing where it's a map button and a lot
of video games but that's a beer trapper
hmm oh maybe looks like a guy you can
hang out with maybe should we go visit
yeah let's go see what it is
I feel like this we initially were gonna
do like a first like beginning minutes
stream then we're like nah that's we
don't want to do that boring beginning
part and really let's just do like
random story stuff this is just an
adventure stream now it is we're just
going on random adventures and red dead
with everyone you can do some stories
some people want to see it but I imagine
a lot of people don't want to yeah too
much of that I feel like keeping away
from spoilers is probably a good call
hey hello
alright so Ben another one I like is
putting the compass one on which
minimize makes it very minimal on its
but my horses I don't know why I got off
that's weird is it possible to use human
shields in the game and can you kidnap
people for ransom I think you might be
able I've seen people get grabbed I
don't know if you can actually like
human shield it only had an opportunity
to and as as far as like holding people
for ransom I know you can hog-tie people
and take them away yeah I don't know if
you can like make demands for anything
but that's there but yeah I like the
compass here because it's like a smaller
you know kind of you're not like Oh
constantly looking at it to see what's
there but if you just need to sort of
know the general direction to go in
the compass one works pretty well yeah
so I highly recommend people mess with
like this stuff and you can kind of turn
off and on when you want which is really
nice I like keeping it off for the most
parts yeah I kind of like it too the
match kind of really big
it is robbed a train could rob a train
it is really fun to just kind of like
exist in this game's world and just do
stuff and walk around like really into
it kill a legendary animal then speak to
the trapper to make a holster or animal
hats animal hats well we're gonna go
talk to the trapper right now so we can
draw Luke your animal hats this is just
Monster Hunter i'ma hit basically how
many different pants can I make in this
video game hold on make sure I'm not oh
he's a stranger thing he's a giant
stranger whoa whoa I'll come back to
that in a sec right now I'm going to
cross this and pray that train doesn't
start yeah I'm waiting for like the the
sound of the whistle it's gonna be a
thing so let's use the app if you can we
don't really have it I haven't
downloaded I can try to like make it
work I don't know if we have to like you
want a connector thing but all oh I'll
check it out for you they're legendary
fish as well you can fish in this game
camp yeah the fishing is apparently a
very good minigame or game it's there's
it's a game part I haven't done it yet
myself but it looks really rad oh I get
to see if I can actually sign into my
Rockstar social club which hardly ever
happens I hear the train it's fine you
got you have tons of room to move around
and you'll never get hit by the train I
also hear the train
shoot it's there there it is well what
was that you hear that that's a wolf
music whoa it's like I yelling about
oh I don't hear the guy yelling mr. the
wolf well this guy just yell oh Jesus
hello hello sir is everything okay
see over here hello I don't know what
this guy is I've never done a CAPTCHA
for an app on my phone
Oh what those you were right in that
tree I ran in that tree and then I flew
up like 5 feet the horse just like the
thing I saw was the horse kinda like
popping up and then just like flopping
backwards anyway where is this guy Oh
is he all about wolves why would you
make me do a CAPTCHA if I put in the
wrong password Rockstar just take this
guy's stuff while he's not here I mean I
think so I wouldn't I mean unless you
want to be like maximum outlaw I mean
that's pretty good name for a video game
max maximum outlaw rest by campfire all
right let's try for this dude where is
he
yo I'm in like triple down the horse
crash physics are really good I feel bad
for the horses but man they're so good
all right where is this boy
this gonna work ah another captcha cool
it's getting late
well I can at least use this guy's camp
so once these down by the train tracks
oh okay I guess I must have passed him
me he's a trapper so he's probably out
actually like trapping stuff is that
squirrel running with you
how's that was yeah there's like a lot
of wildlife in this game oh wait that's
a horse no we have a question for you
guys as long as it's a cool question
well the guy will do our best to answer
it for you by the train tracks down the
river so I also want to like do a
another go just like my horse got
spooked they do a real cool thing with
different types of guns in this we're in
the first game you'd have revolvers and
you'd have duel like double-action
revolvers and you'd have semi-automatic
pistols but in this game like
lever-action rifles have to be each shot
takes two pulls of the trigger or with a
regular revolver each shot takes two
pulls of the trigger because you'll you
have to pull the hammer back you also
have to pull the trigger to shoot it and
it feels really good oh yeah so like
with the lever action rifle you aren't
just shooting you're you have to shoot
pull the trigger again to like do the
lever and then put it back and then you
get to shoot again let's get this wolf
oh yeah I like that I like that a lot
I'm gonna try to keep it I'm gonna keep
trying to hack into my Rockstar account
with this companion app okay so well uh
she's a white dot on the map if you can
if you find that what my dude I had a
dude we're looking for oh I found him oh
no I saved him so it's trying to hack
into my Rockstar account I aim to see it
so I'm going to I wonder if I can store
multiple pelts because I can only
probably get one corpse or carcass I
guess can I get a second
pelts I did it I've successfully hacked
into my Rockstar account very nice
searching for live games searching for
offline data please connect to red
totally can you can put two pelts on
perfect it's great all right let's take
this wolf so as you can stack small and
medium pelts crime with the with the hot
tips here sorry if I missed the question
being asked the first time the gun wants
to know how do you get the companion
Abbot
so you just search it out on like the
iOS store or the Android store and it
should find it it's just RDR - companion
and make sure it's the one from Rockstar
and you just download it sign-in and I'm
I'm doing it right now trying to figure
out what's going on where I saw this guy
got strategy guides journals a social
club feed catalogue where'd he go oh
this is the actual like Rockstar catalog
not like an in-game catalogue is this
guy just like off I can't uh is he like
open up the map is there like a like a
white dot around here at all no I don't
know where the trapper one huh probably
got skipped probably got got maybe so
it's an animal carcass fool like decay
if I take too long I was gonna sell to
him but he's not here you know what
that's just rest by the fire and see
what happens
I like it so looks like it's just like
you can you can open up a map there's
some like general tips stuff the
companion app doesn't seem like there's
too much going on
but I also can't connect it to my game
for some reason then much cooking so it
might just be not working for me right
now but I'm LinkedIn it's there
download your companion app check your
maps on your phone
cooking ourselves some but that way
search up it was by another developer
weird we'll try again later today thanks
for the help for sure I hope you're able
to find it i I just found it this
morning myself but you got to kind of
scroll a bit because there are people
who put out their apps that are supposed
to be like fake ones way before so it
maybe it'll surface up later on like you
said so he eats the food off the knife
it's such a badass all right it's night
time a guy he's got to sleep it's true
it's true we gonna steal this dude's bed
I can take his oatcakes don't take his
oatcakes it's all he has all right we
should probably head back to the camp so
I like how you've been you've been
carrying around those those skinned
animals and you have blood all over your
shirt because of it it's kind of a weird
thing that you wouldn't really think
about right when is this coming to PC no
clue but I hope it does that'd be nice
that would have been not good
so there's another good tip from
Frederick he says search our dr2 and not
red dead redemption for the companion
app do searching for apps on on it's
really weird
yeah remember when I try to find like it
was when we were doing like the the pub
G when they first went mobile oh and
everyone else had already had apps off
that are not anything so you type in
like player's unknown you type in like
the exact same name and it's still like
the forth thing yeah and I'm like this
is not good
I heard it's supposed to be a beta for
online next month any truth that yes
they have announced the resume there
there will be a beta hey there's a guy
over there I feel like I feel like it's
a very safe bet to say that we're going
to try to play with you guys in that if
we can because a gold a gold person
looking for gold go by get doing it's
good to see you
that it just saying good luck this old
prospector good luck my dude here we go
here we go
go back what he said here we go I like
did he find some you used let the wolf
see the rabbit he's speaking in codes
let's uh all right let's see if anything
happens
punch him punch him John Luke oh that's
cool
give him a punch y'all are the goats if
you let me play with you all hey that's
that's what we do every normally every
Friday this is a chance for a good promo
normally every Friday that Brahma is our
our community day where we try to play
games with you guys new releases old
games that are just fun to play whatever
we can and I feel like the Red Dead
Redemption
to online
beta test would be prime for us to try
and play with you guys so if you do want
to hang out be sure to follow the
channel subscribe to it so you don't
miss a single show we stream every
single day at Olympia cific our show
that we do is on Friday I can do skit
Ternes now with the horse heck yeah
horse drifts did you should have punched
that man should rob that man I probably
should have taken his gold it's waiting
on my game to install got a few hours
left I feel that yeah there was a point
in time god I almost said last week this
week's been very long where I was like I
need to just digitally buy this so I can
preload it because it's like in 90 gigs
to make sure that everything's set for
when the game actually launches it's a
beefy game it's on two disks physical
disks that's wild
it's wild to me ready give Bret
when's the beta on the beta sorry it's
next month I don't know the exact date
but look out for it will let you know
you'll know we'll all know and then
we'll all ride around on our horses
together it'll be a wonderful time Jago
was just as shocked as you were boobs
here yeah boobs hanging out it's a good
it's a good day alright let's uh post up
our horse here turning this carcass I
brought a bunch de animals for you guys
man maybe we should go check out
stranger mission yeah yeah let's do it
can you twirl your pistols like ocelot
oh my god can you I heard I heard a
thing at one point that if you tap the
like ly no I think like with your with
your gun out oh boo thing ah or is it
just pooping this game like in real life
horses just kind of poop what I'm just
gonna do it yeah it's weird they don't
squat they just kind of do it I'm
pooping now it just happens it's a fact
of life they mind tomorrow it takes long
you install obviously worth it
definitely set that's the other thing
too like
this is kind of a cool way to hang out
and just kind of see the game while I'm
sure everyone's downloading it or maybe
people are at work or school and they
can't play and we get to hang out with
you guys while we play a game that we're
all excited about it's a good Friday see
oh yeah the gun trick thing like pull
out your pistol I can't do it in the
camp oh stop step outside the camp let's
do it I need to know just a sec I'm
gonna I'm gonna sleep oh we have better
lighting for that we gotta make sure we
can properly see this morning sleep till
morning go south of Valentine town the
railroad tracks not too far another one
rail rows a small bridge you'll find
your fun crimes giving us all sorts of
crazy tips can't
that's a riddle yeah that's there's a
riddle happening there new journal entry
I also like the journal all the journals
fantastic journals really cool morning
Dutch oh yeah you kill that guy yes I
did not it's very dramatic when you do
when you don't kill Martha just gives us
a really big speech cuz he's like he's
like oh you know oh sorry I was I was
mistaken and then I was like well here's
the thing I really was there and I
killed a lot of people too
do I have a reason to kill you and he's
like uh I hope not
Oh Mike's in the chat now hanging out
getting excited about coop it's a mess
we're all really excited about group
here sure okay what crime is saying we
gotta go south a Valentine South a
Valentine mile bridge so here you should
try the gun thing though she tries a gun
thing well yeah I got a gal the cab will
go we'll go here okay I'm just really
excited about flippin guns around
understands should clean that horse it's
covered in blood yeah that's no it's a
real gross look
man
Shh okay right at the camp you want to
see the gun thing right so it's how do I
do this I pull my pistol all right why I
just tap it so apparently if you like
tap it or something you're like which
one the the shoot or the ll 1 or R 1 or
something well one is just putting it
away yes shoot I just shootin that just
shoots so what someone was saying
something about doing gun tricks
somewhere I think it was in a slight you
know what you you continue on your
journey I'm gonna try to forget all
right if you can figure it out cuz I
want to I want to get to the bottom of
this I would like to know as well
there's done gun flip tricks are very
important to me they are
someone says you can do in first person
maybe that may be it Oh kind of like a
like in Metal Gear Solid 3 yeah yeah
yeah if it is just like in Metal Gear
Solid 3 I'm gonna know my mind it looks
like a not good situation dude quarrelin
shove em in directly in the chest and he
still okay yeah I missed that guy
ton of times so fun fact about the Old
West people who got him like saloon
gunfights you would miss like 80% of
their shots and exact everyone's fire
from the hip actually see I'm not the
best when it comes to the gunplay I'm
still kind of getting my handle on it
it's all good
so I one time a wooden why I wanted to
do a strangers quest I had to go inside
a building which the Driscoll's were in
front of and I couldn't get in without
harassing them and so then they shot at
me
I killed them but then apparently the
law didn't like that and I had to go to
jail uh my best experience with the
patient's name is also my only
experience so far where I was sprinting
up to try and get on my horse and
apparently you can tackle people and I
figured out that I literally tackled
this man in the middle of town and
everyone like stepped back in these two
police officers were like hey what's
going on over here Shawn supposed to
turn up the game volume I can do that I
can do that um and I tackled the guy the
cops were coming up to me and I was I
was able to talk them down and be like I
mean nothing by it officers everything's
fine oh don't even mess with me and they
actually like let me walk away and the
guy like accepted my apology and I went
from being in a wanted state to not
being wanted at all because I was able
to like explain my situation yeah I
surrendered but I couldn't like explain
cuz I was thinking like hey like those
guys shot at me first like can I explain
it
yeah
okay south of the train tracks south of
Valentine train tonight it might be over
here I don't think I'm able to find
where I saw that maybe I'm making things
up maybe I'm just sleep-deprived in
delirious oh it's like blood this is a
murder scene
oh I'm willing to call I think this is
what crime was talking about it sounds
like a real a real tongue and robber
kind of thing look on my works you know
killer thing I'm down to launch a full
investigation detective Arthur Morgan is
on the case is there anything we can do
about an hour it's just kind of a set up
for later
you gotta check out this gnarly much
louder than the game that's the way I
kind of balance it I want it to play
like the le noir like dude
yeah yeah it's like when I like check
all my clues that's how I know that uh
I've investigated everything in the area
also the the games there isn't too much
sound going on there's like quiet music
and horse trotting games very subdued
yeah this sort of the thing about this
game is it feels like it um it wants you
to play it at a slow pace yeah and I'm
totally okay well like the game feels
very intentional in its pacing and it
wants you to play it very slowly I think
that's going to turn some people off for
certain like um my girlfriend doesn't
like open-world games or cowboy games in
general so oh she's like yeah I don't
think I like playing this game but she
is enjoying watching it for the story
mm-hmm
but yeah I think I think this game is
gonna be kind of hit or miss depending
on your feelings on the games like
pacing Oh apparently we're supposed to
find the the head for that oh that
person let's go back then we got to find
a head there's an actual actual mystery
afoot oh let's do it
I don't wanna miss out unless so DX has
just got my copy about to jump on it
heck yeah man
did did blast nobody I kill that guy oh
it's all checks out to me okay okay
we're back we're back let's look for the
head well that seems to be the head that
seems to be something I don't know if
it's a head so it's got a first person
here for a proper close investigations
it's really gnarly yes that's pretty
gross
I'm not gonna lie the first Red Dead is
it is such a good time and if if if
anyone out there still is yet to play
Red Dead Redemption one like it's still
even worth playing after you played two
it's definitely worth playing after to
play Red Dead Redemption one day Red
Dead Redemption sooo yeah
videogames have a good time I don't even
tell you what to do oh there it is hi oh
there's a note hmm
it's really lodged in there whoa nice
this is a rated and stream yes for gore
ah okay first part of a map killer me
[Music]
killer clue one piece so I'm guessing
we're probably gonna find more more
victims and probably put that all
together follow blood trace oh can you
actually track it so click the matching
oh oh there you go get you track on this
this is perfect it says it wasn't me I
didn't do it that might just be for this
like oh there's a leg there yeah there
is there's a whole leg on the ground so
it looks like this is probably where he
was killed then initially only found one
don't know where the rest of it is hey
that's a good tip on how to start off
that that murder mystery though yeah
thanks for the hot tip yeah I think that
was just so we could find a head okay
yeah so looks like we just should keep
an eye out for for that yeah yeah that's
cool how much does this game cost it's
the usual sixty maybe sixty four
depending on your tax you'd have to pay
but a six dollar video game yeah thank
what country you you're in a so those
are hunting bears for Crocs do you know
what just realize the what is like
staying on your shirt I know I got a
probably like bathe right and that's
that's like I usually just kind of
dissipates and goes away
yeah that's just that's just staying
there yeah
any PC players here sup guys I'm still
hoping that this game comes out on pc i
want i want all games to be out
everywhere so i want everyone to
explicitly do i am overwhelmed with
bounty poster let's do that there you go
let's go do a bounty
get my horse don't forget you can max
payne dive with Deadeye it's true you
can how do you do that okay Paul aiming
pressed the jump in any direction yeah
he took out the roll it's how I jump
jump on its square okay
oh that's the reticle still there sweet
all right good to know this game has a
lot of buttons yes
and it's it's a bit overwhelming for
sure uh we had called the trail Oh like
I thought the trail away I thought the
trail stopped yeah yeah I it's like it
went cold oh now it's got cold I can't
believe it yeah we've met John running
with John at this point John we're
hearing his it's the same voice actor
and I was ecology oh right he's oh he's
got a very distinctive voice it still
sounds kind of younger though I don't
know if it's just because like in my
mind I'm like he's younger he's younger
and I'm singing it over and over but no
no he didn't sound about different he
didn't sound older or anything really
yeah it sounded exactly like John and I
was like oh wow like that's honestly
kind of cool he's got that guy's a river
distinctive voice what system is this on
we're playing on a PlayStation 4 pro but
it's also available on the Xbox as well
[Music]
take a gander at the poster what's the
best weapon so far I haven't gotten to
touch on a lot of things
I'm loving the just bass revolver like I
was talking about it earlier I love how
the revolver and like the lever-action
rifles are now like you have to pull the
trigger twice because you you're pulling
the hammer back and then you're also
pulling the trigger so there's there's
more of like a tactile feel to it but my
favorite weapon in Red Dead Redemption
one was the bolt-action rifle and it's
still in this game I really hope it
still holds up because that guns
[Music]
some guy says whoa so I got my ps3 in my
flat
too busy with private life and a job to
clean the dust removal whoa generation
really has got some amazing looking
games dude if you uh if you eventually
have some free time or uh and some cash
you're able to get a PlayStation for
cheap there are a lot of really good
games for this generation that are at
this point pretty cheap you can get it
like you know blood-borne I'm gonna
study him study this dog had that dog
pet him in first person oh this is good
this is good content this is what I'm
here for
oh he's so excited morning look how
happy the dog is it was like I got a pet
come on go over here and it's gonna pee
on that that tree broadly so Downey uh
do let's go do some bounty do the cheat
codes come with penalties in this game I
feel like they'll probably turn off like
trophies and stuff is he gonna actually
be on it let's find out he's sniffing it
doing it Toby's a good Tony's a good boy
oh he's just seeing he to say hey I'm
giving him the praise anyway he's a good
boy he's a good he's a good dog if we
run into any alligators not yet this
part of the map there is a river or like
a lake I felt like looks like an
alligator like that yeah let's go hunt a
bounty let's let's go find this social
station shack for God's sakes hey man
this is showing the extent of how gross
Arthur can get let's just hear it was
real dirty how dirty can we get in one
hour and a half stream
apparently pretty gross oh gee coach
turnoff achievements but you also can't
save so that's good oh so just kind of
like I'm I want us to have a fun time
fun time not worry go back to yeah buddy
green is this spoiler free yeah we're
just kind of doing like side stuff and
going on and adventuring we're we
haven't hit any story missions yet but
if you're if you're sensitive about like
the possibility of running into a person
in a stream doing something weird this
guy in the river
oh yeah we're not gonna get into like
heavy story spoilers or anything I think
some crazy preacher all right bye dude
yeah pet that dog you're playing the way
I'd play it fortunately don't have a ps4
or Xbox waiting to play it with my
friend next week hey I'll be a good time
I'm glad that we could help give you an
idea of what to expect in the dog
petting experience of Red Dead
Redemption to stay stay tuned guitar the
boys the best best boy hi ray all these
boys of 14 out of 10 hekia that I can
give you a rating on is how good the
dogs are these are very good dogs
no the other thing my girlfriend likes
is dogs oh god I'm gonna put my song
he's like I'm not really into westerns
I'm like you can pet the dog and she's
like best game ever
Viper wants to know how are we like
Arthur Morgan's voice actor I like him I
look like his voice actor a lot
I was worried first but after hearing
him like there's so many opportunities
for him to actually say things and he
does such a good job with it
I like his dynamics with all the people
in the camp
yeah I just I like his voice actor a lot
real real good yeah crime saw that arm
he saw it so what I saw arm arm did a
thing it did like a good thing
can you investor by properties I don't
know I feel like that's gotta be a thing
in the game foot I I can't say for sure
to tell you that there are people who
are calling for us to shoot shoot the
horse I'm not gonna do that this guy's
that guys so people are saying that no
one's done it yet because no one wants
to do that
dick I wonder why I wonder why no one
wants to do that
I'm down for crashing the horse into
like rocks and stuff I still feel bad
about it though should we so where could
download the Skyrim mod he's out of here
I think we can hope they have pets
online I hope there's a lot of good
stuff in online like I I really really
want there to be like the train I want
to be there I'm hoping that in eight
years we've progressed so far enough
with technology that we can have trains
and online pets I'm looking forward to
seeing what the character customization
it's like I feel like you can make your
own character
yeah yes e-version I hope eventually I
should probably not I whispered you
don't want to start yeah hey Olli I hit
him but he's not he's not going down
dang I thought I got it that was a
pretty good shot guys feeling it too man
that's brother
it's alright though you just got to
track him down it's definitely not
having a good time I think yeah
unfortunately and the meats not gonna be
as good now that's fine there are always
other opportunities for better meat I
missed oh I thought I had that oh yeah
if you hold it too long he kind of oh so
the another good tip from for crime has
been just just cranking them out study
the animal first yes you do want to do
you do want to study the animal that way
you can figure out the best weapon to
use that's like a double tip crying oh
man I came around dang he put it up and
I alley-ooped it cuz I knew what the
studying but I was like I'm too far away
you didn't use the binoculars to do it
why is this in our tips video I didn't
watch it I probably should I should
probably what about this video oh that
birds just kind of uh why is running so
weird in this game converse I think it's
cuz rock star just has a weird
for
oh did that arrow just it's good to see
it's still aerodynamic on its way down
uh the running is were than this cuz I
think that's just the you put in your
bag
oh no he's carrying it now I'm taking
the bellies that's a big bird I'm
surprised take the bird though just
because of the way that Rockstar does
bald eagle
I can't arrest it don't do it you're
gonna get a grip open its skin again but
I did that what was I gonna say I'll
remember in a second where was I Oh God
you pick up arrows I can breath of the
oil yes yes oh yeah the running tip so
you can actually change the way that
sprinting works and we actually did at
the beginning of the stream yeah so now
I don't have to hold it down so you just
tap it and you get into running pretty
good I should stow this this bird ah
yeah that's where the ego lets go
alright abouty oh that guy's seems like
he's sounds gone out he's looking real
rough
she do I need to get this woman dead or
alive did they say
the guy didn't yell at you like he did
with the last one so I think you're free
to do whatever you want what if I can
check that what is the survival element
apprehending or alive yes so the the
survival stuff isn't like off you never
eat yields straight-up die but it's yeah
these things called cores which you can
see at the above the mini-map and that
is like your represents are different
like stats
yeah and it's sort of like maintaining
those and keeping them in good shape
that's a fantastic way it feels less
like like a bad like survival sim where
you're constantly babysitting a
character yeah and more like like I said
it was just the game just kind of asking
you to take it slower yeah so I keep I
keep seeing the the question about a UFO
pop up I haven't seen anything heard
people talking about it I haven't seen
anything myself but it's rock stars so I
believe it watching this one at work
heck yeah Michael I'm playing this at
work exactly okay where do you think she
is oh there we go we've got we've got
confirmation
what night the mist said the youtuber
did do the the horse shooting thing
everyone's asking us to do and nothing
happened confirmed
do you think I could kill those guys and
take their criminal and then get turned
into banging myself yes
ah a little way to find out but I'm
already here to get my bounty man double
the bounty double the fun Shh I try
should I try killing them now let's try
and find my person are the survival
elements overwhelming I don't think so I
don't feel like they are at all alright
I think the gone there are German
Shepherds in the game I haven't seen one
but I hope so what do you think shotgun
a repeater I take the repeater
that boy is gonna die
that boy is definitely gonna die what's
going on over here
you almost shot him
oh no Jude did she just kill me she did
what job look what I didn't even know
what happened she ran up on you was
stamped you in the throat
yike Rudy's cuz I didn't want to kill
her cuz I gotta take her an alive you
know yeah yeah
yeah but you saw what I saw it also I
don't have my carbine anymore let's find
you a David gun if your your revolver
maybe at maybe I should just shoot her
now sure she'll like there we go grip to
talk tired oh no what oh no this is bad
jeez
this bounty is going wild
yikes no it's trying to save you tire up
I think she's alive right I think you
just knocked her out
oh there you go yes hog-tie it salute I
think she's dead oh gee you can't
hog-tie someone who's dead that'd be
silly no wait she she grunted cuz I did
just kind of smack her
yeah hey man I was trying to save that
guy yeah maybe uh that that's me maybe
you have to like let the dialogue play
out to the point where he's like I think
I'm gonna turn you in maybe but then
like her stabbing him yeah that what's
that Stefan was was intense
alright let's uh let's loot the camp
before we revolver cartridges I do feel
like ammo is it's kind of limited but
it's not like super limited which is
nice I lost my hat oh shoot where did my
hat go
it's probably somewhere on the ground
over there geez gotta make her get that
hat back I'm gonna take this Apple take
this canned salmon hey remember when
that woman stabs you and one hit you
yeah it was good that was intense
see this Kentucky Bourbon that's a very
good call okay got herself some nice
loot and one for the poor fella but you
got a bounty everything's good we just
take it back now get that money
alright
[Music]
sure that is a very good tip from Golden
Eagle if you hold down oh I think I have
one on my horse anyway if you hold down
the loop button you can actually
continually loot stuff that's in the
area good tip so you don't have to like
individually hold it down for each one I
think I could use a lot of tips like
that like small small little
quality-of-life tips yeah yeah we
actually have a tips video I haven't
watched it so I don't actually know
what's in it simply so sorry Joey if
you're watching the stream it's it's
been a really busy week for everyone I'm
sure it's an excellent fantastic tips
video that you should get for me 100%
watch and I'll probably watch it after
this actually yeah same feel bad about
this no you try to stab me do you
remember the last the last check point
that I had to reload because you stabbed
me in the neck
oh well you can hit them I don't I don't
know good about that though no it's I
think it's more than anything just a way
to like shut up cuz you knew with anyone
you have a hard time it's kind of
interesting that after this happens they
kind of give you like the the like
talking to while you're riding him back
[Music]
it's a very pretty game how do you stop
the train and Red Dead Redemption -
should just have to go up to the actual
engine car and pull the brake if you
talk about the beginning yes she's going
through all the levels yeah there's a
lot of like bargaining depression anger
acceptance has got to be coming up real
soon
see if there's some incentive in playing
the game it's more of an outlaw storms
giving bribes not to rob them uh I ever
seen anything like that I feel like the
the outlaw play style is gonna end up
being like it's gonna be rough to like
hang out in towns but you're right there
so even after I did a crime and I went
to jail for a bit people like I couldn't
like over the barber or anything they're
like no we don't want to serve you yeah
I know I feel like you'll make it more
difficult in the long run are you doing
I'm gonna try to let's see how it works
out I feel like it might lead to more
like the horse can't run faster so I
think if depending on how much
equipments on it or things are on it it
might change its speed also someone says
you need to like kind of get your level
up with it yeah gotta get your horse
bond up become friends with your horse
the landscape here is epic real
attention to detail boulders rocks
stones pebbles trees yeah all of it it's
any time you look at anything in this
game it just looks really you change the
radio stations it's a good question I'm
of the mind that I don't think just cuz
the game visually looks good makes it a
good game but I have a good art
direction too for sure but I do think
this game has a attention to detail that
I think enhances the experience yeah
what's the jail ledger I don't think
that's your reward that's cool though
you can look at that anyway how much you
want to bet some of the gang members
show up in that book at some point ooh
that'd be interesting
this town's so starved women can you rob
a stagecoach whenever you like I feel
like you'd be able to yeah you just have
to find a stagecoach do a crime try
doing a real really crime you can put up
put up your your we should probably go
geez divert been going for an hour and a
half oh wow
good lord we should probably go at least
another what half an hour and then maybe
stop hey whatever you feel like
I do got other stuff I gotta work on how
I get my hat back you were saying I can
get mine it's on the horse like in the
actual liquid nl1 and then not that one
or l1 not r2 or l2 there you go and then
uh items on horse r1 Owen oh sorry
Apollo's there you go and there's the
Harrier so we got two hats on ah you get
your hat back okay I'm and or hats good
to know
alright we do a murder spree see how
long how long he can last or you got a
two hundred dollar bounty on you that's
not good
do i no no not us how they do Adam in
the chat nose nice okay yeah what do we
want to do with this last bit here shut
up I want to hear what Arthur says my
bad
we can try robbing a stagecoach I'm
talking about that try to find one yeah
I think there's a lot on the path back
to the the camp yeah lots of people
moving and going you kill the horse and
eat it probably well when we find a
stagecoach walled I guess we'll find out
do that sick people people got questions
man that guy's not happy about that at
all now definitely not
that's a wagon I want something a little
little bigger can I pull the gun here I
can do like a proper
it's a check in a little I saw a thing
that might be a thing so I just moved it
out witnessed a murder so I guess this
is just the start of like whoa he kept
running we gotta find that other lady he
did promise he wasn't gonna say anything
though I don't know then the stagecoach
ran away yeah so you know you're not
wanting any more okay no you gotta go
catch that siege coach I know we gotta
go catch that stagecoach get the loot
off but those other one already come by
and their people are investigating this
giant scene you've created weird the
stagecoach that's gone now it's gone
forever
what dang it dang alright we'll try
again does that guy I was like ready to
rob that dude and then he was like wait
what Oh
oh geez okay I know you did the murder
oh my god
what the what is happening
you're covered in animals uh also uh
what it is how violent this game got
holy crap literally she made dudes head
off you did you definitely did hold on a
sec sir I just want to talk I'm not
wanted the perfect way to end it
Yeah right that's a bit of a spree so
maybe can you shoot up the wheels maybe
I need to shoot the wheels
maybe that could be a thing or maybe you
do have to just shoot the horses oh hi
I also do kind of like how you can't
just pull the trigger hold one you have
to like kind of you feel like rapid well
not even that but like if you actually
wait you're shot something more accurate
you can do like the like revolt like
calmly and hit like repeater things but
you will be less accurate there are a
lot of people here
all you got that camera going alright
hold up over here on this tree looks
like a good tree what they just take
shoot my ball I think they did the the
the YouTube chat is alive and well
chasing after whoa yikes
no they melt as well as I expected
dang I'm now red dead I'm actually red
dead okay I want to try and successfully
rob a stagecoach
okay you got this I believe in you you
make you can make it happen
when you still have your bounty still
keep my bounty that's nice
or not okay just get back onto the road
back on the main road there it would be
kind of cool if you could like mess up
the actual wheels no I mean the
alternative is just shooting the horses
and I'd rather not shoot the horses well
I use a shotgun if I'm shooting the
wheels right yeah I feel like that might
be a better choice okay this menu takes
a minute to kind of get in there get a
handle on I do it like further away from
the town if I can so no one can get to
you really quick
there's a there's a guy up there should
we Robin give it a go like hey give me
your money
okay I'll do the horse thing I gotta go
calm this horse down I don't want no I
wanna shoot him yeah calm him down
you're getting hoarse points with this
random horse I am and now I'm gonna lose
all these worth points wait a minute
you're doing that worst thing yeah if
you wanted to see right actually I don't
see this might be a lady horse these are
the things they're up here to not be any
sorry oh it got a it didn't like that I
was looking I feel like I feel like
that's appropriate but anyway what they
want to know if we could eat it yeah I
think I was can can you
yikes you see like the if you wait for
the the shots and all they'll be more
accurate I'm kind of down with that oh
no it's still runnin your train
robbed the entire train
you go for it you jump on it oh you
should be able to
yeah we're all the strain now
drivetrain like you can actually drive
the train driver trailer
excuse me
accelerate keep accelerating to the
point where this train derails itself
because if anything about Rockstar Games
is I know about trains is the thing is
that you can make a train go too fast
and eventually fly off the rails
hold the damn train Joe
ring that Bell use that whistle oh geez
dude I got people on me now probably
probably oh no I just hears me oh so
steel trains and drive them I didn't
know that I don't know why you'd want to
drive it oh why wouldn't you why
wouldn't you wanna drive the trains a
good point it's a good point so thought
it would just be like I'll pulling the
brake and releasing the brake kind of
thing okay I feel like we've
sufficiently uh I don't even know where
we are anymore
test of the limits here am I even okay
yeah you just you stop the off to the
side it got really big bounty dang yeah
I don't know if you feel like it's a
it's a good break point
let's get point I think we've chased the
red dead heck yeah go off on some some
crazy cool horse adventures yeah you uh
once you close out bring it back thanks
everyone for watching happy Red Dead to
launch day yeah hope you you all enjoy
the game have a good time yeah we'll be
back with our normal community Friday
stream next week yeah is there anything
coming out
what if we just played her into the one
like online online oh yeah there are
people there also a lot of hackers but
hmm maybe think about wanna do it we'll
figure out a thing it'll be fun be there
11:00 a.m. Pacific Friday's we also
stream every every weekday at 11 a.m.
Pacific video games all the time
yep dude don't be a fool stay in school
played Doug and Robin yeah kazoo
keep it real all right bye Ben
goodbye everybody I'm gonna find the
buttons now hit that button been doing
it found it I got it